so YouTube this is not so much of a tech
video as it is an update so I'll name
this one on next
the update series probably update 2.1
and this one i'm just going to go over
like a few of the tutorial ideas that
I've had in plans for the future
first things first I just reached 450
subscribers today I passed a hundred
thousand video views and ten thousand
channel views all in the same week so
I'm really happy about that I'm excited
about that and I thank you guys for that
the second thing is that I've got a
whole list of tutorials pulled up on my
notepad document here about exactly like
what I want to do what requests I've
gotten and what I want to cover a few of
them are how to do call-outs in Camtasia
Studio 6 how to explore Mars in Google
Earth and Google Mars and how to get
free ringtones a few other things like
that
a few more software overviews downloads
tutorials etc so things like that how to
get more free software I already have a
free software tutorial if you visit my
on my page so if you haven't already
subscribed you're going to want to do so
because I got a whole ton more ideas
left that I want to present you guys on
the next part is that I finally got this
camera to record by the way in the
highest quality that I could it might be
a little distorted but I'm still working
with that but I'm changing settings and
the camera changing settings in Camtasia
Studio 6 trying to get everything to
work out right so hopefully this works
out well um the next thing I was going
to talk about was I'm probably trying to
do more hardware stuff today right off
today but over the course of the next
few weeks because I've obviously got
this camera you guys watched my video on
the HP Pavilion media center remote and
that got about oh that got a few honors
if you go check out that video was
really good I do have my ipod over here
I have
my new LG Voyager so I'm going to try to
mess around with some hardware I have
obviously my laptop here and maybe even
a room tour at some point so I'm just
thinking about those types of things for
the future and also in this video I have
to say that a lot of my older tutorials
like I said in an earlier update a lot
of my earlier tutorials were recorded
using temps to you and the combination
of camstudio and Windows Movie Maker
when I was really back in my first
really tutorials were not very good
there weren't no number one they weren't
very good because they weren't the
highest quality even though they were HD
and number two there's the zoom and
everything was messed up and number
three the audio kept breaking up there
would be certain glitches and you could
really hear what I was saying in terms
of audio so this is going to be I'm
going to be posting video responses to
those old videos I've actually the new
rear recorded version the more clear
edited professional version of the
tutorial I didn't go so whether it was
glitch or an audio breakup or just
something that was unclear so I won't be
removing those videos because I still
like the video of you account of course
but I'll be really recording those and
posting them monthly responses so
basically I got a few more software
tutorials a few more hardware tutorials
and I want to get you this week and I'll
release them again on a timely basis
they not overflowed with videos but
that's basically it so um thanks for
tuning in to this update videos update
2.1 another inboxed video is coming up
soon hopefully Friday I'll do an inbox
video where I read off some of the
memorable questions and put the out the
link in the description to all my
subscribers that actually submitted a
question
sorry it's 1:00 o'clock morning so yeah
that's basically it that's what I want
to go over in this video that's what I
got for you guys and hopefully you'll
stay tuned and subscribe thanks for
watching
peace